tenemos más información para ustedes
aquí en prada 24 y hablamos ahora de
economía estamos para eso con luiz
mentes que nos va a contar lo más
importante de hoy bienvenido el acuerdo
entre la unión europea y el mercosur
está en suspenso cuéntanos por qué se
llena esto por la preocupación que
existe en el francia en torno al tema
medioambiental luego de las
declaraciones que expresó el ministro
francés yann castex en las que además se
presenta toda la preocupación por las
series de informes y organismos
independientes que han presentado todo
lo relacionado con los detalles la
deforestación pone en peligro la
biodiversidad y altera el clima el
informe presentado por stefan apec
confirma la posición de francia de
oponerse al proyecto de acuerdo unión
europea-mercosur tal como está de ello
depende la coherencia de los compromisos
medioambientales de nuestro país y de
europa así lo expresó a través de un
mensaje en la red social 'twitter'
además el representante de la
administración de manuel mccrone
sostiene que se debe mantener las
negociaciones y garantizar
la deforestación y el respeto a los
acuerdos de parís por el momento países
del mercosur ha manifestado que evitarán
responder a la posición francesa pero
escuchemos lo que nos dijo el profesor
en derecho internacional ricardo
arredondo sobre este tema
[Música]
a ocultar un tema de fondo que es la
insatisfacción de los agricultores
franceses con los términos de acuerdo ya
el año pasado cuando el acuerdo con este
acuerdo en principio se firmó no se
firmó pero cuando se llegó a este
acuerdo en principio con tuvo consenso
sobre la base de la negociación los
agricultores franceses se levantaron
picos y palas y tractores y se
manifestaron en contra de este de este
proyecto de acuerdo entonces lo que lo
que sucede ahora es lógicamente puede
haber algún tipo de de
reticencias por parte del agricultor y
franceses sobre el acuerdo y eso es lo
que está llevando a macrón a buscar
alguna excusa estética para bueno y el
desempleo en brasil alcanzó nuevos hitos
en agosto louis así lo reflejan datos
del instituto brasileño de estadísticas
y geografía que sitúan la cifra de
desocupación dentro de la población
económicamente activa en un 14.3 por
ciento en total ya son 13 puntos 7
millones de personas que no encuentran
empleo en brasil esta es la mayor tasa
registrada desde mayo cuando el gobierno
comenzó a medir nuevamente la
desocupación a partir de los efectos de
la crisis causada por el nuevo
coronavirus la pandemia impactó a brasil
en momentos en que aún sufría los
efectos de una severa crisis económica
en la que se sumergió durante el periodo
2015 2016 en la que el producto interno
bruto perdió hasta 7 puntos porcentuales
brasil es una de las naciones más
afectadas por la pandemia de coronavirus
y es el segundo con más muertes por esta
enfermedad en el mundo con unos 135 mil
decesos
es el tercero en cuanto al mayor número
de contagios con 4.4 millones de
infectados bueno y la economía uruguaya
registró una contracción en el segundo
trimestre del año así lo dio a conocer
el banco central de uruguay presentados
el día de hoy de acuerdo con el
organismo la economía de esa nación ya
contrajo un 10.6 por ciento entre abril
y junio si lo comparamos con el mismo
período del año anterior esta situación
se presenta debido a los efectos de la
pandemia donde la falta de movilidad y
las restricciones impuestas generaron
toda esta situación a pesar de ello la
ministra de economía a su cena arbeleche
apunta a que la nación registrará un
crecimiento para el trimestre actual y
los indicadores de la jornada cerraron
con números negativos sobre todo por el
impacto que existe en torno a las
tecnológicas por la situación entre la
aplicación víctor y el gobierno
estadounidense mientras tanto en europa
también se dieron números rojos del día
de hoy por toda la incertidumbre que
existe en torno a la pandemia y sus
efectos mientras que en américa latina
los datos de desempleo de brasil
influyeron negativamente en las
principales bolsas de la región
y la ciudad del día en este caso tiene
que ver con los datos de las principales
empresas consideradas unicornios dentro
de américa latina
la oración del mercado en este caso
tenemos a new bank de brasil con 10 mil
millones de dólares que es la que más
valoración de mercado tiene entre las
cinco principales unicornios de esta
región graciasluis por la información de
colombia ellos de gracias continúen con
más aquí en france 24
ah